all right Jake we had a chance to check
out operation phantom sight year for
season two of Rainbow six siege this
brings with it two new operators a map
rework and some tweaks to our favorite
sniper operator good old glass so who's
your favorite of the two operators I
think my favorite was knock knock is an
attacker that's basically just vigil
except an attacker her gadget is called
help presence and basically it lets her
hide from cameras and apparently when
you activate her ability she has a
little bit of a silent step not as
silent as calves mini calves some people
said they didn't really notice it other
people other people who are at the event
did so that'll be something interesting
to test out one that's in the wild or in
the test server my favorite thing about
her though oddly enough is her design I
think her design is so cool she looks
creepy she's got that like chainmail
face beard thing doesn't look like in
her bio like all of its been redacted I
don't know if you saw that too which I
thought was pretty cool but her guns
didn't really blow me away too much at
least nothing stands out there was the
fmg9 the 612 SD 5.7 USG and the d50 the
one interesting thing about the d50
which is basically a desert eagle is
that you can you can put a silencer on
that bad boy that doesn't pass the smell
test but it's a video game and I I
enjoyed using it more than I should have
yeah and then I think the and then she
has claymores and breaching charges -
what did you think she was good at what
she add to the game I think where she's
gonna come in the most handy is during
that final push when she can hide from
cameras she can flank
she can almost roam a bit more than your
other attackers she can kind of split
off because the cameras aren't be able
to see her she can kind of make her own
path she's gonna be very difficult for
coordinated teams to call out you can
still take her out line-of-sight but it
there's less of a chance of you knowing
you know where she is and then you play
a lot of the other operator warden what
do you think of him warden is a really
interesting guy he's there to be
resistant against any kind of flash
bangs or blinding devices and he can
also see through smoke or see better
through smoke when he's standing still
he's there for what seems like a very
specific type of tactic
I love playing his gang and he
counter sure candelabra really well it
just shows up is nothing there's just
flashes but he sees everything totally
so you might have too much confidence as
an attacker going into a room after
flashing it which to be fair is usually
a problem in siege unless you're certain
operators one thing I did notice is that
his ability though his smart glasses
they do have a long cooldown it's
something that you're definitely gonna
use when you know you're about to get
pushed the other thing him seeing
through smoke really impacts those just
people breaching on windows using smoke
grenades and in this case he could
completely flip the script on the
attackers because they will only be
blinding themselves with the smoke and
he can be just inside the window
dropping people seeing through smoke
directly impacts the rework of glass
whose thermal scope now takes a lot
longer to get a thermal image while he's
moving yeah so if you're moving now is
glass that thermal ability will
disappear you you have to be stationary
for a little bit before it goes up and
then if you move again you're gonna lose
it this is supposed to pull him back
from being such a frontline attacker and
make some more of his owner I'd say
however the people we played with at
this event we're still pretty good with
glass and seemed to hang tough just fine
using line of sight yeah so it wasn't it
wasn't quite that big of an impact but
then the other big thing that's coming
along with phantom sight is changes to
Cafe Dostoevsky which I may or may not
have mispronounced but from what we saw
it seems like a pretty smart redesign
it's not a huge redesign it's not like a
here for base redesign it's very simple
it's more like the biker bar the German
biker bar that they just kind of fix
some line of sights at a new line of
sights got rid of some line of sights
change the layout to some areas like the
Kitchener in particular was quite
different and I think the kitchen is
much better now
the most noticeable one by far was
making two entrances in a window into
the meat locker at the back of the
fridge that's always been a very closed
off area in the game and defenders never
had much visibility into it and
attackers only had one way out of it if
they wanted to fight their way into the
kitchen so there should be a lot more
dynamic movement around the the meat
locker area
after these changes mm-hmm the other
changes the map that were mostly as you
mentioned small tweaks like moving
stairways and things that unlike some of
the other maps I don't think you're
gonna around a corner and just not know
where you are in a building kind of like
you know the biker bar
yeah and then some other UI changes we
saw were a shop redesign and then the
rank tab has been reworked which is also
sound sounds like a good addition help
those rank players out the interesting
thing about phantom site is these
operators felt inevitable but they're
not game-changing and according to a
community manager siege is targeting
about a hundred operators potentially
and we're about halfway there yeah a
hundred operators is like the goal the
the dream goal they had talked about
whether or not they hit it I don't know
I hope that through a lot of the
operators going forward aren't going to
be just flips of offense and defense I
hope they do some really cool and
interesting stuff like I know you talked
about having like a ladder operator
which is basically there for silent
rappelling essentially that you can set
down or you can go up through hatches
yeah I think something like that would
make a huge difference in this game but
yeah I'm really hoping that we get some
operators that are more game-changing
not too much because I don't want to
mess with that formula too much ones
that add new strategies in interesting
ways if you have any creative ideas out
there or an operator that you have been
dying to add to this game based on
something and say real life let us know
in the comments below we're headed off
to e3 in June where we're gonna cover a
ton more shooters so make sure to stay
with us over at GameSpot calm and we'll
see you soon thanks for watching
time limit reached
[Music]